en direct de lourdes avec nous nous
retrouvons soeur emmanuelle
bonjour soeur emmanuelle la venue du
pape à lourdes est effectivement un
événement exceptionnel comme disent est
ce ce petit garçon dans le reportage que
l'on vient de voir
viens voir évidemment mais voyez-vous
pour moi le plus important c'est
exactement ceci c'est premièrement la
vierge relie à dieu le pape relié à la
vierge et petits hommes ces femmes ces
jeunes redit au pardon c'est l'humanité
entière qui est symbolique
aujourd'hui il est symbolisé de sorte
que je crois moi je crois du jeu quand
loeb
je crois que dieu seat armée pour seul
et la plus-value pays sourit à lyon
merci serait manuel pour ce cri de joie
et de bonheur et nous vous retrouverons
évidemment un petit peu plus tard dans
notre édition pour cette visite du pape
à rome à lourdes par